hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba no
I'm John Humphrey we are finally gonna
be covering that final episode of Black
Mirror the Miley Cyrus one Rachael Jack
and Ashley - got a couple things to
mention numero uno if you guys are going
to comic-con I'm actually gonna be
hosting a panel at comic-con Friday July
19th more details to come soon specific
times and whatnot tentatively Friday
July 19th for the new 8 episode series
called dark web this comes from the
creators the Netflix movie circle I'm
excited to be doing this and a nervous
but there's gonna be is and more details
to come just want to give a tease for
now secondly want to thank Eric over at
nerve chronic for editing this video
down for us to go up on YouTube YouTube
only allows for 10 minutes worth of
reaction highlights to be included Eric
his work you can find over with Iman
snow acha saw and does some work for the
Schmo down has his own podcasts on
youtube wherever podcasts are found
lastly full-length reaction stream along
for this will be available at our
patreon page we do us your marks or many
shows that include supernatural haunting
of Hill House Cobra Kai season 2 Gotham
attack on Titan my hero academia one
punch man Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood several of the shows also
have reaction highlights included at our
patreon page those are attack on Titan
my hero academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood supernatural from my
understanding this is the highest-rated
episode of an all-black manners history
[Music]
futuristic cars I stay oh no we don't
watch him
it's a mice die no no it's humane mouse
control its Mouse loves am I gonna
transfer Miley Cyrus's license it them
house I'm just trying to get one
prediction right the song is the feel on
brand who had some synthesizers and
maybe like really speed up the tempo are
you changed to a major king hey I see
everything okay yeah I'm fine you taking
your meds yeah you know what don't worry
about me okay alright see you at
breakfast this is gonna have a happy
ending how much your [ __ ] money is
that sure oh I don't care what people
say that thing is adorable that's my
girlfriend's birthday happy birthday
Olivia she loved this episode that's so
cool this make people feel like they're
actually friends with Ashley
after choosing a Trump you like don't
get in the way of my friendship you
wouldn't have heard of it hi
Pixies Sonic Youth idols savages all
those foreign bands
hmm more like vintage yeah Ashley she's
a good listener she waits receives the
information and then appropriately
responds with another questions just
great great then she's ashes you must
have read had I wouldn't friends and
influence people dude she's a better
friend than a normal for him that's a
good point other day I walk in she is
writing somewhat ruse [ __ ] twenty
people are gonna relate to and no one is
gonna buy
she's Ashley oh not Leonard [ __ ]
Cohen told you wasn't even like that
song yeah like anything real then
there's that thing I learned from movies
as music managers hate what they want to
create there's this um it's talent
contest at my school next week singing
and dancing no way you have to enter
you'll be awesome yeah I I don't know I
guess
I actually kind of kind of like this
song it's a good generic pop song break
the door down whoa that is uncalled for
yes
you've got 20,000 fans waiting to see
that you they love it doesn't matter if
it's the real you Hey
[Music]
whoa how do the main characters never
actually taken her medication combadge
on its gonna go splint it this is gonna
be like Napoleon Dynamite he just lays
the dance down and everyone loves it and
Pedro wins president
you got this Rachel oh god Rachel this
is to a great start you improvise unlock
your greatness Oh
it's crazy how the song cut out exactly
when she felt it was almost as if it was
quite no that was the failure mix no hey
Ashley
I read your journal and watch this
heading camera that we put it here file
everything you see and what Ashley has
to do is transfer her consciousness into
an Ashley - and then wake up all the
other Ashley to come take revenge like
so she's just wearing this leather
jacket while she's chilling her job
she's a rebellious rock star that's sure
she's rock and roll a she was gonna
punch the Zipit where is he Harlan
where's Ashley this is about our
addiction to hot toys garbage talking
toaster what Ashley was filling her head
with crap hi I'm Ashley - I'm your only
friend kiss my feet kiss my ass
I hate you I hate you - think I can get
Ashley to endorse Mya humane mousetrap
[Laughter]
Oh God don't desperate to break away Wow
oh you think you know how Shh what was
the plan
od make me look bad first out of the wig
making sure the lights stay on you sit
down no because I don't have to listen
to you anymore but you will sit down no
I won't yes you will
like a program in her you owe something
there's some foods [ __ ] there's
something in her eye powdered your pals
- and put it in your food ah nevermind
non-program I got a little far-fetched
look for all kinds of things
Oh God let's see that part of the flood
what am i that's that's actually the
creative center hole so this guy's a
doctor might take what they learn look
on earth what we discovered that
although we couldn't communicate with
Ashley we could read her brain waves
using a temporal interceptor once
plugged in what they heard stopped them
in their tracks
music she was still composing music in
her head in her dreams Oh dumb I had no
idea what's happening in t-shirt I'm
sorry if I pissed off anyone no no yeah
this is odd yeah
[Music]
this is cool it's gotten so ridiculous
I'm into this yeah
stabilized didn't got a clear ball this
is it nice and friendly
what is this based on anything real
increase the positivity what okay we can
work it's a hit song if I can make it
into the house get in range of my laptop
I can bluetooth onto it and download all
the evidence that I need can you guys
take me over there yes what did you do I
do what I had to
you killed her wait y'all listen I know
me okay and I know I wouldn't want to
exist even ten minutes in that state no
no what about God please mom saver
wedgie
wooof like very gonna have a happy
ending
hey Ashley - came in handy she better
not be able to stand up after all oh my
god we have to stop her stop
oh my god is this a hologram show it's
crazy how she made so many apples off of
one superstar head
the most accurate and versatile
holographic performer in history
photorealistic and fully controllable
right down to instant costume changes
this isn't disrespectful to a woman in a
coma at all nope this is how the public
would respond it would be all about it
like oh my god this is why she would
wander right she can appear in thousands
of locations simultaneously imagine an
entire nation wide tour there one extra
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so really weird certainly it's like a
teen comedy right we gotta get rid of
the show what if Black Mirror turned
into one of those movies halfway through
this dad's gonna kill us oh oh they even
drove to right into there yes
hmm we're all can I just live on through
the Holograms Oh
oh why is that the one she's right in
the piano maybe I was gonna be the man
with him yeah give you control
Ashley [ __ ] oh I'm so glad we watched
the do we did it I was so happy I have
nothing this happy you know no peace my
brains back together okay so um the
first 20 to 30 minutes I was like all
right I'm feeling a little detached this
is a little weird it's kind of moving
awkwardly it's weirdly paced not much
has really happened or the real hook
here or is this gonna just turn into
like the black mirror episode version of
that bo burnham song about pop music yes
cuz it's gonna be like the tragic biopic
tale but with a black mirror twist to it
yeah where we like see what the fans are
being done yeah and the middle point I
was like this is so dumb and as a
wedding I started going I think I'm in
love with this episode it's just so not
even like bizarre in a black mirror
bizarre kind of way no it's just like oh
my god this is so unnerving like I have
no sense of that at all one of the cool
things about black mirror that they can
do is how they can hit close to a sort
of a near distant future type of touch
something that feels like this could be
our reality down the road playing on
something real right and yeah maybe
toying with pop artists and whatever
like what exactly is this [ __ ]
episode
talking about it this is so dumb in so
many ways with some [ __ ] entertaining
throughout yeah I mean it looks it felt
to me like Charlie Brooker sat down and
was like I want to do an episode about
the pop music industry and then just
brainstormed a whole bunch of ideas
didn't structure them very much and then
just put them all in the sand yeah some
of it is like okay maybe we're gonna see
this interesting parallel of you know
the pop stars image but we're gonna peer
behind that and then we're gonna see
what that does to the kids late into the
episode it becomes this is the dark
future of the music industry where like
if your manager doesn't like it they'll
just copy your body and a hologram ever
well that's what I mean it had no sense
of realism the way the public was
responding this is obviously not so far
in the future seem like they have some
slight futuristic touches because the
hologram tech already kind of exists
like they've already done live yeah I'm
a hologram but it would like the AI toy
and the cop car you know like slight
slight touches of the future were in
here some slight technological
advancements the whole thing with the
public in the hologram right there I'm
like the public would not react this
there's there's no way Wow any
resemblance of realism this would be a
Twitter outrage right here this would be
something where people will be in fury
the fact this person's in a coma right
now and they're doing it I don't know if
it walks around well enough in the
society side of it to sell that point I
mean I can understand the cynicism of
going oh yeah the the audience would
just want this to continue and I get
that like oh the managers deceit is
supposed to help sell that as it stands
it's like she goes into a coma six
months later they're touring and there's
like no ethical debate at all about that
even like the whole villains of this
episode just felt so unreal weirdly like
the first half I was waiting for this
thing to like really pull me in because
it just felt like a real detached
episode because of the way it's all
moving and we're cutting back between
two different storylines Edwards house
is gonna connect right around the part
where I thought the whole thing with the
brain pulling songs you're a brain no
that's me the heart is so no so dumb
that's so silly I start to think is that
the one piece of technology in this
episode that's actually
real aside from the Rams or something am
i good yeah it's so wacky the idea that
they're pulling music notes and songs
and I'm like are they gonna be in any
order or is it just gonna be like yes
she's been aware of and played musical
notes before of course there's a G and a
c-sharp in there and like all sorts is
not but you can make whatever song at a
certain point I would have been less
distracted if they were like let's just
bring in two songwriters and use the
voice module that we you know obviously
money I thought they were gonna like
clone her something yeah when they said
we did a new one when they put her in
the MRI scan or whatever can you have
these random ideas probably would have
been better than that but the thing is
when it got when it crossed over into
just the most ridiculous territory and
then it just really went off rails from
there it's like all logic got thrown out
the window just them getting into the
home and even like the distracting games
that are doing and how they make it from
Malibu to wherever the hell this pitch
meeting is at and they break in and it
becomes a teen comedy of like finale
oh so dumb is so ridiculous so silly I
couldn't help but I couldn't help but be
so entertained by it like I'm really
enjoying this it's I really enjoyed yeah
it's like oddly enough in creating such
a weird alchemy of tones and plot points
and and yeah half future isms it does
just become this really compelling neon
mess of ideas that sometimes are they
just random times are fun sometimes are
so wacky that you yeah you just have to
laugh a story like this I don't think
they could use everything this was it
was actually yeah and like this could
have been a two-hour movie yeah I was on
board for when they unleashed the
consciousness and the Ashley - it's just
like a swearing Miley Cyrus or a little
robot I thought that was cool I'm like
like why is this occur 45 listen to this
one hour episodes [ __ ]
earlier I thought that was a fun detail
that came back where they had the news
clip of the Grove I told my daughter she
flipped out and then that comes back
later like I thought there was some like
small things that were handy but then
even so the whole thing like with the
dad and the mousetrap like I thought
that was going I had no payoff your and
I'm in and yeah and some kind of
meaningful way but really it's just to
be like oh yeah the mouse so that she
can shock him at the end well most of
the ideas they had in here were only met
about 50 to 60 percent of the way
doesn't they just crammed it all into
this really like there's so much lack of
breathing room and it spans so much time
I really feel like this episode could
have been broken in half because yeah
the thing about the biopics side of it
peering into her life is that it does
start to feel like just scenes from a
biopic because there's not enough time
scene where they're talking about like
okay you know you don't want to go and
do your work and stuff and I have worked
so hard for you and then Miley comes
back with the like well it's my
creativity and it's like I've seen this
scene in like 12 movies yes I feel like
they could have had an interesting
commentary or something if they just
made this episode or if they split it in
two and made one episode about Miley
Cyrus and her coma and the hologram
because that's real and people have died
and hologram tours have been put on and
there are ethical discussions but people
still turn up so in that way that could
have been an interesting thing and then
you have a separate episode where it's
like here's the relationship with these
kids in the robot doll version and the
effects of the pop and the music
industry on you know young people or
whatever but as they stand together yeah
just becomes as a wild like movie like
she says stream-of-consciousness in here
and I kind of felt like I was watching
in a first outline thought Miley Cyrus
did a great job even even in the
voice-over work for the Ashley to when
Ashley to is unleashed I thought she was
great
I thought her subtle you know dramatic
moments I thought she was very
believable in there I thought the two
sisters rigueur I know I'm like Madison
Davenport I think it's real from from
nestled on I thought she was really good
the other daughter was good and from the
new the nice guys right isn't that the
daughter she's grown up now this is a
lot of she's she's a little bit of TV
kid you know yeah ya know I spent part
of this episode like how is she like 20
yeah
the dad was good a whole villain people
who manage oh there's so cartoon is such
a cartoon and it's the writing of them
honestly the no amount of good acting
could to save that I can't hate I can
see why this is the lowest rated episode
of Black Mirror I can I can definitely
see that it's such a mess to me like the
first half of my okay guys this is kind
of like not really exciting the first
half like the first half this isn't
really exciting but I don't get why this
is so awful what people are complaining
about but when it just starts tumbling
downhill this is so much more engaging
this is so weird
and not in the right ways we went to a
wedding so we didn't have time to cover
it then we have to catch up on e3 and
all these other things honestly before
filming like should we cover it we cover
this I don't really want cars everyone
seems to hate this episode it might just
be boring and I was like that's my one
fear is that it's gonna be just an
episode of reality
so the first 30 minutes I was like I'm
wearing a leopard I'm worried about this
yeah but I gots insane I was like I'm so
happy to be watching it just ends
Portage's and so that one has this
button like what I thought that that
that note of attitude on the very end
seemed like it had a distinct purpose
and I am totally lost as to what that
button what does that mean jail I'll
kill myself like what does it mean yeah
I have no idea like [ __ ] it what right
this could it should have been the
episode that felt closest to reality
like now and in terms of like how we
absorb celebrities and daddy or Miley
Cyrus to be in here yeah this should
have been the one that feels the closest
to our relationship with celebrities and
the internet or media and should have
been the one but it put mantilax focus
this episode is is it's a lack of focus
not to mention like celebrities and
their own persona because like not only
do we have just Miley Cyrus and her
growth into an adult and what that has
been in the pop music sphere but also
she played Hannah Montana
which is all about a regular girl with
an alter ego and stuff like that so yeah
it really is like the perfect casting
and she does bring a lot of that life to
it but oh I think it's unfair when
people say like she's not really acting
she's playing a pop so I'm like this is
still acting keep it sure even when even
when you play yourself you're still
you're still acting so smart at home
with her Lansing like to be realistic
yeah to do all that rhythm to get to the
point of like tears or anger or even
like the real subtle emptiness which is
kind of what this episode was it's kind
of hollow let's see one could argue it's
a hollow episode because she's all over
I'm like I don't think that was
intentional love for her is hollow yeah
and then she joined her band that was
that was cool it was cool right there
and I was cool and and what happened
whole thing with my daughter at the end
she gets to be a fan okay really even
though she's the real there's no art
cute what's the art like she gets along
with her sister now I thought there's
gonna be a whole thing with overcoming
the grief of losing the mom like there's
no real payoff here the dad still like
freakin struggling to get is is random
business off the ground and like there's
no real arc except for then they learn a
little bit more about how the world
works and they experience a messy
situation but yeah like our lead ends
the episode just being a fan of this new
band
yeah and having her as a best friends
that was special this I will never
forget this is my favorite episode or
the best experiences I've had her
reaction is arguably this is the
shortest episode and the one that
deserved me the longest every time it's
gonna get scary it was a program
oh no she's got okay holder they can
like reanimate her like a puppet I can't
get over that the brain site and songs
yeah please Hornet below and confirm for
me that that is ridiculous because I'm
gonna be so mad if that's real I'm he's
so mad at this episode if that's the
thing that's real
when you're in a coma your brain is it's
not like a single consciousness even
though it's out of focus thought it's
just a whole bunch of brainwaves corner
and I get that I get the figurative and
the commentary of having them tweak it
on the sound board and stuff like that
but how good is like pitch correction to
be like throw on two filters and this
sounds like a pop singer yeah
whereas before it sounded like an
apocalyptic noise metal band yeah this
is this is insane thanks for watching
guys - rich annex click that
notification about Sega's on patreon who
- go to sleep bash